[Music]
you've seen them fight as hero versus
hero you've seen them fight as friend
versus friend now the greatest threat to
the Avengers is it's gonna be themselves
again isn't it yeah as what happens when
your villains kind of suck Captain
America Civil War loosely based on the
comic book crossover event comes the
epic struggle that has your favorite
heroes asking is it better to be dickish
Lee stubborn if I see a situation
pointed South I can't ignore or
stubbornly dickish sometimes I want to
punch you in your perfect teeth in a
film that settles a moral and political
debate the only way superheroes know how
by beating the crap out of each other
take that regulatory oversight the
government wants to rein in the Avengers
for when they recklessly say the entire
world from aliens that other time when
they saved the entire world from a
secret Nazi death cult and again save
the entire world from the army of murder
robots they created okay that one is on
them
Ultra iPhone now Captain America must
get in line or face the prospect of an
all-out Civil War or at least one group
sparring session you're pulling your
punches one real fight and a nice letter
reminding us that everything is still
hunky-dory Tony if you need me I'll be
there what you thought there'd be
lasting stakes come on
this is Marvel we're talking about cap
is back and he's still a total beefcake
leading a team of rebels alongside his
quippy black best friend cuz you have to
go mark fuhrman elias hawkeye who's
great in small doses ant-man who's there
Scarlet Witch who's still doing vague
hand wavy stuff and Bucky the man whose
haircut was frozen in the 90s opposing
them as team Iron Man his quippy black
best friend yes this is this is Tony
stank
Black Widow who's still scissoring
anyone she could get her legs around
Black Panther the king of giving
monologues into the middle distance did
it's not the end man Tom passed from
warrior to warrior I can have one of
them find peace whatever the hell vision
is you know I don't know what this is
yeah neither do we buddy and the best
version of spider-man complete with a
pre murdered Uncle Ben hey I'm Peter
Tony if Tony gives him the great power
great responsibility speech I am so out
of here thrill as these former friends
become enemies thanks to the evils emo a
man out for revenge by Framing the
Winter Soldier for the murder of King to
Chaka which will hold on I forgot can we
Rosie Moe's plan again uh-huh yeah
Rex's car really stealing a book okay
not sure he drowned that sink though
okay that makes it there's no way he
knew those guys were gonna show up
wait so we called the maid from Russia
ah the old captured on purpose ploy
someone's been reading Loki's plan whoa
this is dumber than Luthor's not a very
fine Janene display the airport scene
again
ah it's so cool he was like a size of a
net now he's a giant experience of Phil
that's more than just mindless action
it's also about love watch Tony star D
with a heartbreak of dating someone
whose contract expired after I ran three
we're taking a break the weird
flirtation of this weird British
Christmas robot and this weird wedge who
puts him in the friend hole and the
greatest love story of all as Steve
Rogers once again pines for the plums of
the man that only he and tumblr really
care about as he tries to redeem this
brainwashed killer caveman for the
second movie in a row I don't know whom
worth all this to you while ignoring two
perfectly good boyfriends who are right
there in front of his face
ninja Ken and now he has to go in the
run before he can seal the deal with
Peggy Carter's niece 90 years old and
this guy is still a virgin
someone please have sex with Captain
America already hell you know what I'll
do it I'll bend over right now so go
enjoy the hero versus hero movie that
everyone loved instead of the hero
versus hero movie that most everyone
hated even though they're a lot more
similar than anyone would like to admit
featuring a non-superpowered villain
tricking a symbol of America into
fighting a billionaire playboy using an
incoherent plan that includes blowing up
a meeting of government officials and
using the heroes mom's to manipulate
them I don't he killed me that ends with
an ominous warning from a prison cell
and sets up a universe worth of
spin-offs along the way Oh
cue the airport scene again come on ah
that's better
starring Barnes and Noble Robert Downey
jr. jr. Melisandre awesome Oh
Jeremy again er put a bird on it walk
erode the spectacular Sony man Kahala
womb Raider another blue Marvel villain
you know cuz he said Brian Fantana and
giant location headers Vienna Queens
1991 Cleveland wait there's no reason to
get that excited about Cleveland
Captain America three Avengers 2.5 boy
that escalated quickly
that's you right so how did Tony know
that Peter Parker was spider-man but he
just breaking every teenage boy's
bedroom in New York until he got lucky
oh wait hang on that's not really bad
you've seen him in action now learn what
his team really thinks of it Steve has
opened my toll so much Thor can use it
as a portal that has gone if I really
wanted a 94 year old I could just Stan
leave oh no that's a guy who really
knows how to cook you just as Jack Kirby
can't wait for the next move when you
try to do that head scissor thing - Fay
knows and he just throws you into the
fing sign everything is dead that you
love bro screen junkies presents the
roast of Captain America watch now look
at me I'm the captain now does anyone
have any orange slices are you mr. stank
because I stank like mr. stank
I'm not easily impressed whoa a blue car
I trusted you and you ate my Doritos I
put the money in the jacket and the
jacket on the kangaroo and now he
hopping away obtuse rubber goose green
mousse guava juice